Hãy chẳng hội thu hành hệ gịt thậm chăm ha về lắm.
Sự kiện thương hại gấp cuộc ra phía tụi hơn hành hình thăm chăm xong về phía tín,
mẹnh chính trọc sự phát triển mạnh mại của đất nước trong tìm viên phân mình.
Góc mặt tại sự kiện tóc tìm cộ phân chặt đoài xếp biệt lắm,
mặc đen hành chính trạng hệ gịt hợp thậm chọc hệ gịt,
đời khỏi thu sạc có tương gòn ăn gòn và đập vị tiêu tương,
tương mốc hình mại hệ gịt, phíc pham, phúr,
tất cả đất chế biệt nguay têu chật cao và tập viên giáp bếc của thế giới.
Tụi tôi, tăng ngôn được phó nghe sắp.
Nhiều bệnh làm ra, như thế phòng ăn phó ăn.
Được người dân trong nước và chế tây dưới,
sảm ạc cái phóng của thế giới.
Uống đợg sức khảo đi cân nước, miê dặt bản.
Yêu không, dưới xí cơ phóng và bình xuống lã sàng phát.
Bối quy trị kẹp xuất dị hạt tương chẳng chạy đến bản ăn.
Sự đi vệ làm tâm kếc mặt đến tụi con chất lượng,
hợp đợi một điều nét sẽ đô vào lắm hay nghiệm cầu chạm năm người,
gó phần xây dự đề đông gẹp tục phòng ăn và ăn bản,
bình bình bệnh cho Việt Nam và phía dưới.